[Music]
you get the best of both worlds but do
you really Hannah Montana was the
highlight of many childhoods but it put
a lot of pressure on the Cyrus family
stay tuned to find out which
controversial photo got a certain
magazine in a lot of trouble don't
forget to hit that notification bell to
never miss another video and be sure to
check out our community section for even
more fun now let's dive in to the Hannah
Montana secrets because I'm Hannah
Montana Miley Cyrus almost didn't get
the role we can't imagine Hannah Montana
without Miley Cyrus she also basically
brought in a lot of her family and made
the life of Hannah Montana casting team
a lot easier but did you know that
Hannah Montana wasn't originally met for
Miley so you're saying I could never be
Hannah again the first girl considered
for the role was Jojo
no not Jojo see WA Jojo who made us all
sing get out right now from the top of
our lungs the pop singing teen sensation
who came out with the get out song back
in 2004 said she totally got offered the
role around that time Jojo was also at
the beginning of her 7 year long battle
with her record label which is why we
never heard from her until 2015 so
naturally she didn't really want to get
into another contract right away she
said she didn't really want to become a
Disney girl and that she has zero
regrets over her decision
fair play Jojo Taylor Momsen was also
considered for the role and was actually
in the top three alongside Jojo and
Miley of course but seriously can you
imagine your childhood without Miley
Cyrus we can't Oliver Oken isn't so
innocent who let's be honest all of her
stole our hearts he's always so
easygoing and we pretty much know him as
the happy-go-lucky kid burger right now
well kids change as they grow up there's
a
reason why mitchel Musso hasn't really
been in the news much after his time on
hanna montana' back in 2011 when
Mitchell was just twenty years old he
got charged with two counts of DUI as in
drunk driving the police confirmed that
he had illegal substances in his blood
since he was just 20 years old this
meant he was under the legal alcohol
consumption age as well so basically it
really wasn't good news for Mitchell he
ended up getting released on bail but if
he didn't he'd have to face six months
in prison in 2017 he made news again but
this time it was because of his Hannah
Montana inspired tweets there's also
some bizarre things thrown in the mix
but you'll just have to see it for
yourself seriously if you're looking for
Hannah Montana throwbacks check out his
Twitter account he seems to have stayed
out of the news for controversial drama
but as of October 2018 his IMDB page
doesn't show any new developments in the
works either come on Mitchell where are
you Miley's mental health was affected
if there's anything we've learned from
the movie industry is that child actors
need to have a normal life - it's very
easy to get sucked into the life of the
rich and famous at a young age and
simply forget about everything that's
normal that's exactly what happened to
the then young Miley Cyrus and she
admitted her mental health wasn't the
best during Hannah Montana
according to Miley she said she'd often
have anxiety attacks and hot flashes
she'd feel like she was about to pass
out or throw up she said this would
happen a lot right before the shows and
then she'd have to cancel them she
started thinking about how she should be
having so much fun and she couldn't
understand why she wasn't happy which is
a common thought among child stars who
have to grow up and from the cameras we
all know about Miley's controversial
transformation through the years and
that also comes from the effect of being
a child actor but it's really sad to
hear that Miley suffered so much off
screen all while playing such a complex
role on screen growing up is hard to do
but it's even harder when you have to do
it on camera
Billie ray hates the show Billy Ray
Cyrus has been pretty vocal about Hannah
Montana in his relationship with the
show that get-a-grip son they wouldn't
take the car back but I did
do something to beef it up a little bit
he also had some issues with his
daughter but we'll get into that later
as this show started winding down and
hannah montana's popularity came to an
end billy became more and more vocal was
very clear that the Cyrus family has
gone through a lot of turmoil and it
looks like Hannah Montana was
responsible for a lot of it Billy Ray
and his wife Tish Cyrus have had a rocky
relationship the pair has officially
filed for divorce several times over the
years but nothing upset Billy Ray more
than seeing his daughter go through an
extreme transformation into her
adulthood because she wasn't able to
have a normal childhood
Miley experimented with her personality
and lifestyle the moment she became an
adult this all took a toll on Billy he
actually gave an interview and said that
Hannah Montana really did destroy his
family he said that he's gonna face
every single day knowing that his family
had fallen apart in the process the
Cyrus family seems to be okay now but
stay tuned to hear about one of the most
unexpected feuds ever Willow Smith did
you know that Willow Smith was actually
involved in some Hannah Montana drama it
actually comes from a pretty surprising
actor we all loved when he was on that
show
but back in 2014 people started raising
their eyebrows when the 20 year old
Moises arias was lying shirtless in bed
with the 13-year old Willow Smith oh
there are photos we caught what happened
it might seem totally innocent but the
internet was having none of it Moyes has
gotten a lot of trouble and a lot of
people wondered what's the deal with
this unusual friendship while people
were giving Moises the side I will owe
Smith's mom had to step in to clarify
some rumors she said there's absolutely
nothing provocative about that photo and
that the two are just friends in
September 2018 will elbows did a candid
photo of her and her mom on a beach and
tagged Moses as the photographer despite
the controversy it definitely looks like
Moises is family
how did they meet no one really knows
but by the looks of it that dark
controversial photo was just a BFF type
of picture with a shirtless 20 year old
and a 13 year old unfriendly co-stars we
all know it sometimes you just have to
put up with co-workers that'll get on
your nerves
in a regular work setting this might
seem totally normal but it still seems
strange to see a show like Hannah
Montana had unfriendly co-stars it's not
revealed who it is but the situation was
addressed by Miley's grandma Loretta
Loretta said that Miley is or was
extremely sensitive at the time and not
at all confrontational it's not clear
who she was talking about and although
she revealed the details to the
interviewer the name of the actress
isn't known but now we know there was
indeed an actress that gave Miley a hard
time according to her grandma Miley had
made several attempts to win over this
co-star she just wanted the girl to like
her it's not clear just how unfriendly
the actress was but we have a feeling it
was one of the extra we kind of want to
rewatch Hannah Montana just so we can
see if Miley had trouble connecting with
any of the actors on screen for Miley
for no reason Kody Linley's secrets you
might know Cody Linley as Jake Miley's
big love although he was quite a minor
character he did have a lot of behind
the scenes Hannah Montana stories he
also has some dark secrets in 2009 Cody
made the news for underage drinking
he was caught clubbing and many seemed
to have described the scene as drunk as
a skunk basically not a good look for
someone who's just 19 at the time
Cody also shared some of the behind the
scenes adventures on the Hannah Montana
set apparently Larry the prop guy had a
little fun of his own especially during
the Miley and Cody kissing scenes
Cody explained that every time he and
Miley would have a kissing scene Larry
the prop guy would have a fart machine
ready and make the sound the minute
their lips touched come on how awkward
is it for teens to kiss on camera
already and he just wants to make it
worse
Cody also revealed that the kiss is
between Jake and Miley were very
different
the ones between lily and Oliver there's
a reason it's not because Jake and Maile
had a stronger connection it's simply
because after Jake and Miley kissed for
a first time Disney introduced a rule
that actors can't linger on a kiss for
too long
a small peck and that's it Billy Ray
versus Miley this was one of the most
unexpected Hannah Montana feuds and
quite heartbreaking for those that love
this father-daughter duo Miley and her
dad charmed the Hannah Montana producers
with their chemistry but as the show
went on it was very clear that it had a
negative impact on the family's
relationship it got to the point where
Billy Ray and Miley were expressing how
they feel about each other in a very
public way and it wasn't good as Miley
drastically changed her image and
explored different styles of her
personality Billy Ray seemed to have not
approved in 2011 Hollywood Life reported
that according to a source
Billy Ray was extremely jealous of Miley
success Hannah Montana didn't exactly
relaunch his music career did it Billy
was worried about Miley's life choices
and complained about not having a say at
all Billy also said that at the time
Miley had a lot of people around her
that could put her in real danger
scary stuff in 2013 Miley posted a
shocking tweet to her father accusing
him of not replying to her text she said
that he has an hour to tell the truth or
she will at that time TMZ reported that
Miley was allegedly about to expose her
father's affair with another woman under
paid actors Disney actors can make a lot
of money for appearing on a single
episode of the show it was reported that
actors like cole and dylan sprouse made
$20,000 each for the sweet life Hannah
Montana was a worldwide hit and Miley
Cyrus became an instant a list celebrity
that's pretty big right well
Miley wasn't actually paid as much as
some of the other Disney stars or so she
claims she claims that she didn't grow
up spoiled in any way she just wanted to
be on TV but being naive cost her a lot
when it came to her getting paid she
said it herself that she was probably
the least paid person on the cast
she didn't know any better she just
wanted to be on Disney she also said
that her name was Miley on the show but
she didn't own her name she said yes to
a lot of things without knowing how to
properly protect her rights as a famous
Disney actress she said that her mom
started to quickly understand how many
people are ready to take advantage of a
child controversial photos Miley has had
a lot of controversy in the past but not
many know about the controversial photos
that circled the Internet ever since she
was a teenager these came from hacked
accounts and other various candids and
out of respect for Miley and her privacy
these have now been removed from the
internet along with that Miley made the
news as a teenager for her controversial
photo shoots back in 2018 when Miley was
barely 15 she did a photo shoot with
Vanity Fair that raised a lot of
eyebrows she was wearing nothing but a
satin bedsheet the photo quickly made
the news and not in a good way New York
Post headlined the photo and titled it
Miley's shame and Miley herself had to
apologize for the unintentionally
provocative shoot obviously when she got
older she took it all back and says
she's not sorry at all but back then
Vanity Fair got in a lot of trouble for
allowing a teenage girl to have a photo
shoot like that what do you think was
that taken out of context or did the
public have a right to be outraged also
what do you think about how Montana
didn't come let us know in the comments
and that's it for our video don't forget
to subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]